how do we replace our judgment with
curiosity
so there's a simple technique there are
simple techniques to do this one is
write yourself a little reminder put a
little sticky on your computer that says
be curious or ask questions you'll be
amazed how well that works but
especially in times when we're judging
especially when we're in groups of
leaders we're in meetings you know we
can snowball into judgment really
quickly let's say someone's performance
is in decline
immediately they're lazy you know
they're stupid they don't understand
they're a problem child um all it takes
is one person to break that judgment and
say well maybe they're going through
something and there is a technique where
when you believe when you start to form
a narrative about someone or about
something that you force yourself to
come up with 21 possible alternatives of
what could be going on in their life so
are they lazy absolutely that's
absolutely a possibility are they a
problem child are they toxic absolutely
are they going through is are their kids
struggling at school maybe
do they have problems in their family
maybe someone's sick maybe do they have
medical issues that they're hiding from
us that that they're too embarrassed
about maybe like my point is is can you
go through the exercise of writing 20 or
21 alternative stories of what could be
happening and all of a sudden we find
ourselves talking about and treating
that person differently and it doesn't
just come about people it's also about
decisions we're making at work and all
again in a meeting all it takes is one
person to raise a question of what if
um and
as leaders the more we start
asking each other and ourselves what if
or what are the opportunities or what
are the possibilities we'll find
ourselves doing that with our people
that when they come to us instead of us
correcting them and telling that they're
wrong raising questions but believe it
or not simply having a little reminder
to be curious is is really important